make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this
is rob and for today's episode of beyond
omega level we're going way beyond omega
level and discussing one of the cosmic
abstracts of marvel comics
eternity so eternity was created by stan
lee and steve ditko and first appeared
in strange tales number 138 in 1965
and eternity's origin goes back to the
origin of the marvel universe itself
in the sense that in the time before the
marvel multiverse there existed
one sentient universe mostly composed of
a being called the first
firmament and the first firmament would
grow lonely and then create for itself
companions now some of those companions
would turn against the first firmament
and a civil war would erupt between them
and the faction that remained loyal to
it now the rebellious group the
celestials ultimately built weapons that
were so powerful
that they destroyed the first universe
and so the first firmament along with
the astro instead of remained loyal to
it and had not been killed
fled that universe and the shards of the
first universe then reformed into what
became the marvel multiverse now the
driving force behind the creation of
this multiverse was eternity which would
subsequently die
and then be reborn several more times as
the marvel multiverse is now in its
eighth incarnation
following its destruction at the hands
of the beyonders and secret wars by
jonathan hickman and his following
rebirth and so as one of the marvel
abstracts
eternity's powers are incredibly vast so
much so
that he's nearly omnipotent according to
thanos eternity is not as powerful as a
living tribunal but more powerful than
the other cosmic abstracts such as
master order and lord chaos
eternity has complete mastery over time
and space
and can manipulate reality on a
multiversal level eternity possesses
nine omniscience and is also able to
impute others with cosmic awareness as
it did when reed richards was being
tried for saving the life of galactus
which of course
people were mad because in doing so he
basically sealed the fate of all the
planets galactus would devour in the
future including the scroll home world
which resulted in the death of seven
billion scrolls so
reid's put on trial for the death
galactica cause and is only exonerated
after eternity is summoned by the
watcher and galactus
and grants the jurors cosmic awareness
so that they know galactus is a
necessary component of the universe and
since we're dealing with a
nigh omnipotent entity here the best way
to get a sense of eternity's power level
is probably to go over some of the most
impressive things we've seen
him do and several appearances so that's
what we're gonna do here
starting with looking at a character
that's been defeated by eternity in one
of his earliest appearances
eternity is challenged by dormammu one
of the strongest if not the strongest
wielder of dark magic
in the marvel universe even so dormammu
who himself is well beyond omega level
is
easily dispatched by eternity eternity
even makes the comment during a later
meeting between the two characters that
dormammu
is not even significant enough for
eternity to concern himself
with there is an instance later on when
dormammu would combine his strength with
that of his sister umar
and it said that after doing that he
managed to defeat eternity and steal his
power to remake the universe according
to his will
i mean i kind of take this with a grain
of salt though because it happens like
off panel and it just doesn't seem
consistent with how these characters are
typically written but even though it's
kind of an outlier i did want to include
it for the sake of providing as much
information as i could
after one of eternity's battles with
dormammu he was significantly weakened
which allowed
another of one of doctor strange's
perennial enemies nightmare to somehow
blind eternity with chains of pure
cosmic force which allows nightmare to
begin reshaping reality now eternity is
eventually freed when nightmare and
juggernaut who'd been trapped in the
crimson cosmos
unwittingly hid his chains with their
mystic energies because juggernaut
apparently learned how to cast spells
during his time in exile although
eternity states that he could have freed
himself at any time which sounds like
the most eternity thing for eternity to
say right he's like a really proud being
you know it's like well i mean i would
have freed myself eventually
but once freed eternity effortlessly
banishes nightmare and juggernaut into
oblivion and then undoes all the changes
nightmare had made to reality once again
displaying his own reality warping
abilities now another good measuring
stick that we have available to show
us the vast power that eternity has was
something that we covered recently on
this series the story of abraxas now if
you didn't watch that video and you
don't know who abraxas is he
is another cosmic abstract and as the
embodiment of destruction in the
multiverse he's basically
eternity's opposite but abraxis has
always existed within
eternity and to keep him in check we got
galactus however as the various versions
of galactus throughout the multiverse
are killed
abraxas is able to escape and wreak
havoc across the multiverse now when
abrax's assessed his sights on the 616
universe the main marvel universe
reed richards knew there was no other
alternative than to destroy all of
reality with the ultimate nullifier and
then subsequently remake it and so the
fact that eternity is able to confine an
entity as powerful as abraxas within
himself
and is also responsible for the creation
of multiple galactus in multiple
universes shows us just how powerful
eternity is
now there are limits to eternity's power
for instance he was defeated by thanos
when he wielded the infinity gauntlet
and was also imprisoned by the magus in
his quest to assemble the infinity
stones eternity would however
merge with his sister infinity to take
the power of the infinity stones away
from the magus and when the beyonders
destroy the marvel multiverse in the
time runs out storyline
they take out eternity in the process
however as i stated earlier
eternity is resurrected along with the
marvel multiverse now recently
eternity was imprisoned once again this
time by the first
firmament who had actually been allowed
entry into the multiverse due to his
weakened state
as a result of being destroyed and
recreated it should also be noted that
it was not merely an aspect of eternity
that was imprisoned which is what we
usually see interacting with human
characters but the entire
entity of eternity itself which embodies
all of life
in the multiverse now eternity is
eventually freed by the combined efforts
of blue marvel and the ultimate
and then battles the first firmament who
infects him with a virus now once the
virus is purged
eternity remembers his true nature and
summons to his side a group he refers to
as the ultimate ultimate the embodiments
of the multiverse's past now each of
these ultimate ultimates are extremely
powerful entities
one being the originator of magic one
the inventor of science
and one being eternity sister self
infinity and eternity was able to summon
them to his side
instantaneously and so although eternity
is not omnipotent
and has been defeated he usually
overcomes whatever defeats he suffers
even to the point of resurrecting each
time he's destroyed and since eternity
is the embodiment of all life in the
multiverse his resurrection means that
reality as we know it can continue to
exist so with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an
end yeah needless to say eternity is
incredibly powerful right this is a
wildly powerful being and i kind of
figured you guys all knew that right i
mean he's like the top tier of the
cosmic entities in any one universe but
yeah
it's kind of nuts with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end uh if you guys are new here to
kylie's explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
[Music]
peace
[Music]
you